name is Derek gates my film is dead cat
bounce the website is the gcb movie com
b-movie com
Ted compounds is that about training
it's a stock market roll around a
brokered discovered secret stock market
ball he goes head-to-head with a secret
society as devising a plan for one of
her abilities you know we've got to
basically round the economic crisis
going on right now and throwing some you
know a little conspiracy theory for the
young good to get paranoid myself but
then what inspired it are you a traitor
yourself I'm not a traitor but it's just
all of the drama that's going on in the
world right you know financial scandal
markets on the verge of collapsing
political scandals left and right in
such an inch room timely topic I concept
and did you did you raise funds by
shorting Goldman Sachs or how did you
raise I put it all on a credit card all
on a credit card we had a small budget
of five thousand dollars now it turned
out great helluva rollercoaster ride so
far you can you tell us about open film
and then where your film is perilous
park open film it's a contest where
people vote for chopsticks and James
Caan Robert Duvall pickle winner at the
top six and give them $250,000 to make a
feature and you hope to win the contest
you see we have a month to sit on it I
don't find out the beginning of summer
but sue happens
you